we have another guest in the studio
ruyang first of all congratulations we
haven't spoken to you in a long time my
family you got that crucial Victory tell
us about this game it felt like you
signaled from the beginning with your
opening choice that you're here to find
yeah I mean I I was gonna like try to
play some other stuff but I just kind of
gave up prepping sorry like what I
usually play
and um in the opening like I think A4
was really unexpected very ambitious
Yeah by her yes I had never seen this
before did it surprise you yeah a lot
and
what did you base your reaction on
um so I kind of like use like my
previous knowledge of a position like
like what I usually plays like Queen D2
at long castles like F4 and stuff yeah
but like I figure like this middle would
kind of like weaken the queen side a
little like if she wanted to like long
Castle again it would be like much
weaker and I have like B5 breaks later
on yeah and yeah and I just just like
let her play A5 and that's exactly what
happened it feels like combining both
long castle with A4 is a bit yeah that's
a it's a bit dangerous yeah right and
after that when do you feel like you're
finally gaining full control of this
game by the way yeah yeah she had nice
cp5 I realized that like right after I
played it and I was like oh crap like
you know how do you keep your uh poker
face so so I just put so I have to play
Queen takes D2
I was calculating Queen HD2 Rook 6 or
Knight D6 I would assume yeah 986 yeah
King C7 reptix and that is going to play
like night King tasty six or like a 96.
I was like evaluating this position this
is wild yes
she gives you a check you have to run A5
is that it yeah I think A5 or Knight
takes yeah I wasn't sure if I had like
I mean okay but this is some sort of
crazy line yeah yeah
then you can go to A5 and who knows
what's happening here yeah we're not
even try to I think I was like during
the game like instead of um
instead of King takes D6 I was after
Rock takes D2
um
yes yeah I was considering Knight takes
B3 but I wasn't sure
okay Knight takes B3 yes oh Rock tasty
yeah rotation King D6
and I don't know I thought like wild
wild position yeah right computer is
getting very expensive but I honestly
don't think and she played Queen
I was really relieved when she played
that yeah for good reason you picked up
the pawn and nothing bad happened to you
so that's a good thing of course and
after that it felt like your conversion
yeah I think this was quite smooth
you never let go of the advantage very
nice this must uh feel like a relief
after the last few rounds finally get
especially after yesterday finally
getting a victory congratulations
we'll see you after the break
our congratulations as well uh nice uh
finish at the end too I like that very
much Queen D1 check and queen takes E2
and